it's time for it's time for roses and
Rose Day hi everybody we don't have
Rosie
tonight it's white believe it or not we
don't have a frozen of Rosie at this
office did you see the memo about this
yeah
the episode starts with some awkward
silence it's the aftermath of last week
[Music]
little watered down kind of like mixed
tears
tonight we are here to talk about the
latest and greatest episode of The
Bachelor but we cannot ignore the big
big news tonight to celebrate the first
black bachelor or bachelorette lead in
franchise news 3 we've got some ironic
white wine look bottom line
I forgot the Rosie Rachael Lindsay who
is still currently on the scene of The
Bachelor has been named the new
bachelorette and I love it I'm ready to
find love find a husband so as a
shameless plug reminder I was
exclusively on the set of Nick and
Rachel's date in New Orleans and I love
Rachel tonight you guys if you thought
Nick couldn't cry anymore
you thought that wrong it's an ocean so
we saw the aftermath of last week when
Nick like kind of walked out and study
was gonna quit the show aren't you had a
rough day yesterday yeah one of the best
coming on I feel like right now there's
a million ways this won't work out
Nick Phillips set but he bounced back
and we really honest something I love
that mixed in doing about his
relationship with Danielle out the same
thing that happened with Daniella I
think is going to happen with the six
women I have left I would prefer to just
cancel everything tonight get out of
thing Tomas and we head to the beautiful
island of Bimini
so then Nick's got two lights in the
mood with a meat shrimp and they go to
Bimini Vinny
they go to bikini Bimini they go to
Germany I had to Google that place in
the Bahamas I guess vanessa has another
one-on-one date with Nick thing so
really really well sidebar the name of
Vanessa Swan one day was let's go deeper
let's go deeper doc doc doc I just want
to tell him I love him and I'm falling
in love with him but he doesn't know it
I haven't said it but I'm freaking
Vanessa says that she knows and it goes
same way about her but also we know that
there's gotta be some level mystery so
Vanessa I was like this you saw her I
can definitely see a future with you you
can't maybe Mac I am falling in love
with you a lot if I'm lucky enough to
feel love or saying I love you in this
role I'm digging it slow like I'm
leading with my heart wish I really know
what Nick said there but anyway then
Nick is gonna go on a guru day I look
great on eon and props to Corrine for
saying what we were all thinking let's
take my clothes off oh my god I really
felt for Corinne on this episode she
just wanted to be validated and in about
what we all want
I love great-auntie on like I'm going to
validate this glass of wine by drinking
it right now making me very subconscious
Rachel Rachel gets another one-on-one
and things go so well and she's so cute
although we know that things don't work
out for her and Nick and Nick also
spends time with Katrina Katina karena
Nick also played with Katrina you really
cared about her
I think gone all the way to the end part
and knowing what that spike I don't want
to do that anyone thanks again we go
next time Katrina home I was a little
confused by that
I don't know maybe all the tears was
watering down swing I just didn't get it
because he said that he was so into her
and he said he had such a real
connection with her then he really
quickly sent her home
Nick's just doing things his own way and
then we got to see one of the moments
we've all been waiting for
we're current chief is us about Anatomy
my heart is gold but my vagine it's
platinum we got in the audio of Corinne
and next ring two shows over turkey toes
over to dive into bed okay you have to
have two hands on at all times okay
[Music]
bad very bad
no nobody needs to hear that at the end
of the episode we basically have Corinne
Raven Vanessa and Rachel oh yeah the one
who's not going to check that's our
final four everybody and we're gonna
have to see what goes down in his
hometown
I can't wait I've never brought home on
a guy getting closer to Lindsey so
that's where we're at everybody and now
the question will become who wins who do
you think it's going to be as much as I
love Corinne I don't think it's going to
be sure I'm feeling the Vanessa vibe I
don't know she's excited as far as I can
tell
okay have a great night everybody let me
know anything in the final four and of
course the choice of Rachel as the new
bachelorette and make sure to like BP on
Facebook and subscribe to us on YouTube
[Music]
beginning of the beginning after the
answer was it was it was it was that
Nick was I can't remember oh he was
still all upset
Oh God my phone walked up just like
necklace : let's go deeper